BEN FRENKEL: Hi,
just to be clear,
I am Ben-- that
person right there--
and we are extremely excited
to talk to you about all
the different awesome
things that Play
brings to the table to help grow
your games business on Play.
And we kicked off with something
pretty exciting earlier today.
It's about time we retired
the 50 megabyte limit,
and now it's 100 megabytes.
The 50 megabyte limit is dead.
Long live 100 megabytes.
This is definitely
the top request
for a very, very long time.
So, I figured we probably
can't stress this point enough.
JOHN MCGUIRE: Thanks, Ben.
Hi, everybody.
I'm John McGuire.
I'm on the Google Play
business development team.
And I think that's really
exciting news as well.
So thanks for bearing with
us there while it was at 50.
So we're with a bunch
of-- going to need this.
We're with a bunch of game
developers in the room,
but I want to take
a quick audience
poll to see how many of you
have made a mobile game.
So, put your hands in
the air if you have.
Almost everybody.
Keep your hands in the air
if you thought it was easy.
It was one or two, or three.
Well, making a mobile
game is not easy.
And I've done it myself as well.
And I want to take you through
the five phases that we,
and I went through
making the game and then
how play can help you there.
So first, you have
the ideation stage,
and this is really
the most fun stage.
It probably involves a
conference room, some pizza,
a lot of stickies,
and you're coming up
with an idea, maybe the zombie
match-three card battler.
Pretty quickly, then
decide on an idea
that you want to then
bring to a prototype.
And you want to move
as quickly as possible
to get your game on a device.
And the theme of the prototyping
phase is all about iteration.
How quickly can you turn
around feedback in your game
and make the game better?
And once you're ready to get
some real KPIs behind the game
you might move into soft launch.
And this is where you're picking
a territory or maybe several
and you're soft
launching it to get KPIs,
and see how the market's
reacting to your game.
And then finally, if you
decide to launch your game,
that's a pretty
big moment and you
want to build as much consumer
anticipation as possible.
There's a lot of champagne,
a lot of celebration--
BEN FRENKEL: A lot of champagne.
JOHN MCGUIRE: --and
that was actually
the easy part, because
then you have to run
your game as a live service.
And that's actually
the hardest part.
So we're here to
talk to you today
about all the ways
that Play can help you
in these various phases.
Now, we can't quite help you
yet with the ideas phase,
but we might get there one day.
So, Alpha/Beta testing--
earlier today, Ellie mentioned--
talked about Alpha/Beta testing.
So this is a feature in
the developer console.
It allows you to upload in APK.
And you can upload it
to either Alpha or Beta.
There are two important
characteristics of this.
The first is that
users always have
to opt in to either
Alpha or Beta.
And the second is that
they can't leave reviews.
And so while your game is
in the prototyping phase,
this is actually a
really good way for you
to iterate quickly without
being penalized for something
going wrong in a game or a bug.
Secondly, Alpha or Beta
can be open or closed.
And this is something we
launched several months ago--
I think it was two months ago.
So, in closed
testing, this might
be a set of trusted
testers where you actually
invite via email.
So, you have to invite
them, and then they opt in,
and then they can be
a part of your group.
Open Beta, or Open
Alpha, either one,
is where you actually
get a URL, and then you
can distribute that URL.
And anybody with the URL can
download and play your game.
And I think back to when
I made a game in 2012,
a long time ago, we
actually didn't have this.
And this would have been
a really useful feature.
How I would have used it,
is I would have started off
in Closed Beta with a set
of family and friends,
and maybe our game team.
And then I would have
moved to Open Beta
after that to collect greater
feedback from a broader
set of people.
One of the ways you can
distribute the game,
if you have marketing channels,
you can put the URL there.
And I think it's a really great
feature and one that we're
going to continue to build on.
So you're ready to take
your game to soft launch.
Soft launch is a
really important phase
because it's one of
the first moments
where a consumer's
actually seeing your game.
And we've built
some features that
allow you to help optimize
your game during soft launch.
And this is called store
listing experiments.
So, to give some context
the store-listing experiment
solutions that are in
the marketplace today
are expensive.
They are imperfect as well.
And you can see here
a quote from Rovio.
They spent $50,000 testing
over a six month period
their icons and
descriptions in the game.
And that is an
imperfect solution
and we wanted to make it better.
So, a few months ago we launched
store-listing experiments.
So, this allows you to test your
icon, your video, your images,
and your short and
long description.
I mentioned earlier that this
is one of the first times
that a consumer's
actually seeing
your game in a marketplace.
So, while your game
is in soft launch,
you could imagine testing
things like your icon, which
is actually the most
visible thing to a consumer,
and one of the things you
might have the most questions
about during your development.
Here's an example
from a developer
that we work with
called named Kongregate.
You can see here that there's
the-- during their soft launch,
they optimized or tested
their game-- games icon--
and they saw a 91% increase
in the number of installs
they got per impression.
And you think about
the effect of that,
where you're effectively
halving the cost of your CPI,
just by making these
types of improvements.
BEN FRENKEL: When I look
at something like this,
I have truly no idea in
advance which one of these
could possibly work.
Is it is it Mr. Eyepatch?
Is that the best one?
Is it the girl with the gun?
Is it the girl
with the red hair?
Or is it the helicopter?
Nobody knows, it's
impossible to tell.
JOHN MCGUIRE: Exactly, and
that's one of the things
we really recommend is a best
practice during soft launch,
optimizing these kind
of unknown things,
like which icon is going to
resonate well with players.
So you've made the
decision to launch a game.
That's a really
big moment, and we
want to help you build as
much consumer anticipation as
possible.
So, a few months ago we built a
product called preregistration.
So, I'm a big Arnold
Schwarzenegger fan.
There was a movie that
came out this summer that
was called Terminator Genisys.
It had the 1984 Arnold in it
and the 2014 Arnold in it.
And I went to the developer--
Glu created a game that was
in conjunction with
the movie release--
and I go to this marketing
page that they've created,
and I click on the
click-here-to-pre-register
button.
I'm then taken into the
store, where I can then
see a big, inviting
green button that
says Click Me To Preregister.
I then get a notification
that says, hey
when we launch
we're actually going
to send you a push
notification to let
you know that we've launched.
I really like that, so
I click OK, I got it.
I can then go down
the page and see
a bunch of videos of explosions,
some marketing material,
and things of that nature.
I can also share the game
and see what other games
that the developer has made.
We're all busy people.
Sometimes we forget
about launches,
although I didn't
forget about this one.
But when the game
launched, I got
a push notification that says,
hey, the game is launched;
come play it.
So I click on the
push notification,
I'm taken to the store, and
I can start playing the game.
We think this is a really
important feature that
will allow you to build a
ton of consumer anticipation
for your game.
If you're interested
in this feature,
talk to your business
development manager about it.
So that's all the
stuff up until,
and when you launch the game.
Now Ben's going to talk to
you about the stuff of running
your game as a live service.
BEN FRENKEL: See if we
can-- Yay, that worked.
All right, as John
mentioned, you now
have launched your game.
You got it in the
market, and now it's
time to figure out how to
go from merely launching
a game to having a thriving,
successful business on Play.
And Play Game Services, the area
that I'm a product manager for,
is built from the ground up
to support this transition
to being a successful franchise
and a very successful game.
And when I think about
what we're trying to do,
it's about giving people
and developers a way
to create new and exciting
goals for players,
new things for them to do
inside of the game that
go beyond the core game loop--
things like achievements,
leaderboards, Player
Analytics, quest, multiplayer.
All these different
services together
make a cohesive
product that allows
you to be more successful.
And when I think
about what we're
trying to do, our core mission
as a play game services team,
I like to frame it
around the story
of a guy named Eric Froemling.
Eric is the archetype
of the developer
we want to help with
play game services.
He's a one man army that
does literally everything
for his game.
He is the artist.
He is the animator.
He is the game designer.
He's also head of
user acquisition.
All of the things.
But for Eric to
be successful, he
needs to think
about his business
as an ongoing service
he delivers to players.
And a big chunk of
what he has to do right
is to compete with the largest
possible developers, who
have armies of quants,
and armies of developers,
and armies of artists.
So our mission is
to help make Eric
competitive with big
studio capabilities.
And that's what we're trying
to do with Play Game Services
And it really starts
off with the idea
of giving people
the insights they
need to run their business.
And so that's why we
launched Player Analytics
earlier this year.
And Player Analytics is a set
of reports in the developer
console that give you
insight into what's
going on in your game.
And this is a
great example so we
have something called
the Sources & Sink report
that we offer to developers.
And in the buildup to
GDC earlier in the year,
we spent a lot of
time with Eric.
We built numerous prototypes
of different reports
so that we could vet the ideas.
And when we took a
look at the data,
and we shared these
reports with Eric,
we found that there
was a major imbalance
in his in-game economy.
It's a classic problem.
You're giving away too
much premium currency,
but you don't have enough
uses of that premium
currency in the game.
And in his case, he has premium
currency called tickets,
and he was giving tickets
away at an outrageous rate.
And ultimately it was making it
virtually impossible for people
to have a moment in the
game when they needed
to make an in app purchase.
And, so, we gave
him this report.
He was able to quickly
identify clearly
that there was something going
on, that he needed to improve.
So he made a couple of
changes to his game.
And he could immediately
see the impact.
The line switched.
The blue line, the
sinks, actually
exceeded, for the first
time in his game ever,
the rate at which he
was giving them away.
That's a huge
transition for him.
And in three short weeks,
he saw average revenue
per daily, active
user more than double,
and average revenue per paying
user grow by almost 70%.
That's almost unheard-of
impact to happen
in such a short period of time.
And we're continuing to invest
in more reports that drive
additional value for you guys.
In particular Eric--
actually, I have a quote here,
"Player Analytics
has helped me home
in on BombSquad's
shortcomings, right the ship,
and get to a point where I
can financially justify making
the games I want to make."
And, again, we're pushing
the needle further
with new stuff for you guys.
So recently we launched
something called the Time
Series Explorer.
The Time Series
Explorer is a report
that helps you understand
what's happening in the most
critical moments of your game.
What happens when people
first start playing.
What happens just before
they leave the game.
And you have the
ability to compare
different segments of players.
So you can see what
your big spenders are
doing versus your small spenders
versus people who've never
spent at all in your game.
And you can get a credible
level of detail here.
So, for example,
on line three here,
player number three-- he spent,
or she spent $4.99 and then
before that you could
see that they've
earned a number of
different achievements.
And if you hover your cursor
over each one of these shapes,
you get another level of
detail about what's going on.
Just to give you some background
here, what you're seeing here,
each one of these rows
represents a different player,
and all of the unique events
that happen during the game.
And every day, we take
all of these time series,
and we take a sample of those,
and we display them to you
so you can deepen your
understanding-- develop
an intuition about what's
going on in your game.
What's working and not working.
And we hopefully provide some
presets for this report-- so,
configurations that answer a
particular type of question.
So, for example, you
can choose to ask
the question, what happens
at the start of game play?
Where am I losing my players?
Is the tutorial wrong?
You can ask the
question, what happens
before first spend, which you
can actually see right here.
And what we do is we align
all of the first spend events
with each other.
And you can just
scan to the left,
see everything that
happened before they spent
for the first time,
and scan to the right
to see everything that
happened afterwards.
And you can compare
different player segments,
like I mentioned before.
So, you can develop again
an intuition about what's
working really well.
What's getting your
big spenders to behave
in that way versus what's
happening to those people who
spend very little.
And, of course, you
need to understand why
people are leaving your game.
So, again, we have another
preconfigured report here
that allows you to line up all
of the churn events for all
the people that have selector
game in the last 28 days.
And you can scan very
easily to the left
here to understand
what is driving this.
Is it because people are losing
too often in the tournament
mode?
Do I need to
improve matchmaking?
You can discover
all of these things.
And we offer a set of custom
events you can add as well.
So, in addition to all
the default things that
get put in here--
spend and achievements
and so forth in sessions, you
can log your own custom event.
So, any piece of
information you would
like to see visualized
in this report,
you can trivially do that by
adding an event into your game,
and you'll absolutely,
in the next day,
be able to see this data
flow through this report.
And you can develop
an understanding
about that specific type of
data that you're looking for.
And we also launched something
called the Event Viewer.
This is a general-purpose
event visualizing tool.
And to give you some background
here, going back to pre-GDC,
earlier in the year
when we were working
with Eric, the
prototyping phase of that,
we worked with a
commercial BI product.
Something that you
would have to purchase.
And we took all the
raw events data.
We dumped it in this
commercial BI tool.
And we generated prototypes
of all the reports.
But it was in that
process that we
learned what are the
key things-- what
are the types of
reports-- what are
the key types of visualizations
that were important.
And we took all of
the use cases that we
found during the prototyping
phase for Player Analytics-- we
took all those key use
cases, and we put them
into the product.
And so the events
viewer here captures
all of the powerful things
in this very expensive
commercial BI product, and we
made them available, for free,
in the developer console.
Just for integrating
play-game services.
But insights are not enough.
We're all very
happy with insights.
We give you the best
insights in the world.
But you actually have to be
able to take action in your game
in order for the core metrics
in your KPIs to improve.
And that is why we have
launched a feature called Quest.
What questions are are
time-based objectives
for your entire
community of players.
So the canonical example of a
quest is from this game here,
Tower Madness 2 from
our partner, Limbic.
And they have a weekend quest.
And every weekend, you can
see in the games app, which
is a companion app to
all these services,
that there's an upcoming quest.
You can accept the
quest, join the game,
complete the quest
inside the game,
earn the reward in the form of
wool, I believe in this game.
And it's a fabulous way
of re-engaging your player
after the launch of a
game without requiring
your players to actually
update and get a new APK.
So, dynamic delivery of content.
That's a big thing here.
Taking your insights and
moving into the action phase.
So I'll go through a short case
study on a partner of ours,
Concrete Software.
So they've been
around for a while.
These guys are 10, 15
people, and mostly engineers.
And every single
minute that they're
spending on server
infrastructure,
in live operations
is taking away
from what they would
really like to do,
which is work on the game.
And so, with Quest, they see an
opportunity to get a big studio
capability that
would've required
lots of server infrastructure
and other types of support
and they get that for free.
And frees up some time to work
on their passion, making games.
And this their our flagship
title, PBA Bowling.
So John, are you a bowler?
JOHN MCGUIRE: [CHUCKLING]
I'm an awful bowler,
but it doesn't stop
me from trying.
BEN FRENKEL: Everybody can be a
rockstar bowler in PBA bowling.
It's quite fulfilling.
And they have an amazing
implementation of Quest.
They followed all of our
best practices to a T.
And what was particularly
exciting about this use case is
that they've made it an
integral part of the way
they deliver new
content to players.
And here's an example.
So, this is a calendar of
promotions from January
this year.
And you can see, multiple times
a week-- multiple times a week,
they deliver new
content to players.
Like, on January 7th, they
launched the Hammer Black Widow
Legend bowling ball, an
amazing bowling ball.
Honestly, it's a little
scary how awesome it is.
And along with a
new bowling ball,
they had an advertisement
inside the game.
They pushed notifications.
They sent out Tweets and
so forth, social media.
And along with every single one
of these pushes of new content,
they also had a Quest.
And the reason why they make
press such an integral part
of their live
operation strategy is
because it had a
measurable, material impact
on user engagement.
So what they found
when they looked
at the data was that, on the
day that a Quest was accepted,
sessions per user were 15%
higher than their benchmark,
and that that impact was sticky.
After a request was completed,
sessions were 4% higher, still.
So you could understand
why they have
made that such a core
component of the way they
deliver new content to players.
And we're continuing to invest
in this theme of taking action
to insight with the
players stats API.
So, the player stats API is
something we just very recently
launched, along with the latest
version of the Play Services
SDK.
And what it does is it gives
you a way of finding out
information about what
segment your players are in.
So I'll give you an example.
So, let's say someone starts
a session in your game.
They've signed in.
You can call the player
stats API and find out
they're a 95th percentile
spender in your game.
You can find out that they
haven't been in your game
for about 10 days, and you could
show them a glorious promotion,
say, welcome back and
here are some coins,
things you could use
in the game to buy
something awesome for yourself.
And, so, the key
player stats is being
able to deliver tailored
experiences for every segment
of your player base.
And you can get things like
what session percentile
they're in, session length.
And we're going to continue to
just pile stats into this API.
And we think that will deliver
an enormous amount of value.
Another good example
here is, let's say
you want to monetize
your players
through incentivized ads.
It's a very common pattern now.
Some of our partners make
up a 50% of their revenue
through incentivized
ads like this.
But maybe you don't want
to show the incentivized ad
option to everybody.
Maybe you want to
reserve that to people
that are unlikely to ever
spend any money in your game.
So, again, somebody logs
in you call the API.
You can find out they're
a lower percentile spender
who happens to be highly
engaged with the game.
That is exactly
the type of person
you want to deliver this
particular option to.
So, we talked about all
of the different ways
that Play can deliver
value throughout the life
cycle of a game.
And it's still
incredibly hard to make
a good game, a successful game.
But with the services that John
talked about and integrating
play-game services,
those types of things
are the first step to success.
And we can open the
floor for some Q&A?
Questions?
I see a hand, I think.
AUDIENCE: And you
mentioned being
able to check a churn
point for users.
Is that defined by the
developer or is that preset
by the Google Play analytics?
BEN FRENKEL: So,
how we define churn?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BEN FRENKEL: Okay,
so the question
was how do we define churn.
So, it is something that we
set on the behalf of everybody.
But there is a standard
formula for this.
If someone hasn't been
around for seven days,
they're classified,
retrospectively,
as having churned
on the last day
that they played, the
last event we have.
AUDIENCE: And,
say, for my game I
want to flex that out-- to
find it is 10 days or 14 days,
could I do that?
BEN FRENKEL: Not
today, but this is
why we're having you guys here.
This is great feedback.
So, come grab me over some
beers during the happy hour,
and we can talk all
about the different ways
you would like to modify the
classification of a churn user.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]